hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is January 1st it is the New
Year's so happy New Year to all of you
guys if you guys did not check my
community post I didn't mention that I
wasn't going to be posting the dev
stream recap because there was no dev
stream on Thursday that's why there was
no video so it's probably going to be
the same for this week as well a nice
couple days but don't worry I have
something just in case that that doesn't
happen it should be back up next week
there on Christmas leave for two weeks
so that is why there is no dead stream
don't worry I got you guys covered with
content like the one today we're gonna
be talking about three characters that I
personally want to have in for honor
year two I know a lot of youtubers have
done this like Raven and Tony has done
this but I thought I would wanna throw
my two cents in as well we all have
different opinions everyone wants
different characters so I think this
would have been a good video from my
point of view but either way shout out
to the two of them and the person who
recommended I make this video in the
stream last week shoutout to you as well
I've completely forgot your name I'm so
sorry but thank you for that but I want
you guys to understand real quick that
I'm not incredibly good at creating
stuff like this I'm not a very creative
person especially when it comes down to
designing my own character but I'm going
to be mentioning one character
perfection
state their name their class their moves
weapons executions feats and outfits
that will come with their character as
well so let's get started so first up is
the Knights and if you've been on my
stream tons people have asked me what my
favorite character would be and I would
always say the Crusader similar to the
Crusader from Diablo 3 he or she is
going to be wielding a big shield almost
as big as the Crusader himself in a very
big weapon but not too big to where it
requires two hands because he obviously
has to carry the shield with him so a
one-handed big weapon and a big shield
to fit the character this also fits well
with the theme of year two for for honor
because it's almost been confirmed that
most characters are gonna be Vanguard
and heavy type characters and obviously
the Crusader is definitely going to fit
into that heavy class type character for
the weapon it could either be a flail
similar to the conker or a very big
heavy sword
either way the weapon needs to be big to
fit the aesthetic of the character as to
the customization the Crusader will also
have a similar type clothes like warden
with a lot of chainmail armor and a
piece of cloth with maybe a cross on the
front because that's what they fought
for I would personally prefer if the
Crusader didn't have a helmet since I
want some for us since I wanted some
variety and for honor because not many
characters have a full face I believe a
Highlander
and shaman are the only two characters
in the game I think that don't show or
that don't have a mask the starting
armor could be metal of course but
nothing too crazy since it is low level
gear you're just starting out but high
level gear can get on the other hand can
be completely decked out with a lot of
spikes and bulky shoulder pauldrons for
the move said since he has a shield he
could out for a shield bash but it's
heavy so it wouldn't really work out so
well so instead of a full-out jumping
shield bash like conker would be doing
it would be more of a short-range but a
hard-hitting smack with the shield that
would cause a stun effect to the person
hit by the shield since it is so large
he's a very slow but hard-hitting
character and he is there to hold the
objective and stand his ground to
prevent anyone from passing which is why
he's in the heavy class as for the
damage I don't really know to be honest
personally for the balance the light
attack should obviously do a little bit
more damage as to where the heavy should
be the main focus of the character into
a fair bit amount of damage but nothing
incredible like two bars of health off
of a heavy which is incredibly
overpowered the heavy should do a lot
considering the fact that the crusaders
weapon is very large and the speed of
the heavy will be very fast so it's
therefore balanced the heavy should also
have hyper armor because of the slow
speed and should be used more to trade
with opponents instead of swinging
aimlessly the cruciate errs should also
have faints just like any other
character but probably no saw faints
once again because of how incredibly
large that weapon is most saw faints are
quick movements from one guard stance to
the other and that wouldn't be possible
with the size of his weaponry for the
feats I don't really have a lot to add
but I do want one feet which is actually
an ability from Diablo which I'm taking
and it's also used by most tanks and mmm
overalls if any of you have played a lot
of those in the past
it's a taunting and provoking type feed
this feat will be used to mark all
enemies within his area all enemies
marks become debuff to this area will be
symbolized by a circle surrounding him
if the opponent's are within that circle
they will take increased damage and if
they leave that circle it goes back to
normal
so it definitely will require some
teamwork to gain the most out of this
feat the Crusader is definitely one of
those characters you want in a teamfight
he's very good on it he could be very
good on his own but not incredibly well
if he's being ganked but if it's in a
teamfight with his other teammates
that's where he excels the most lastly
is the executions and once again I don't
really have too many ideas for this but
two of them that I would think would be
really cool will be for the Crusader to
either trip the opponent and bash his
shield into their skull killing them
instantly because of how big the shield
is or one where he bashes the opponent
with the shield to knock him over but
instead of a
wind up swing with the sword just right
on top of them moving on to the next
character we now have the Vikings
faction and it's going to be the
Barbarian the barbarian is a wild and
tough looking character that will tear
through armor like it's absolutely
nothing he's going to be the debt he's
going to definitely fit in the heavy
class type the barbarians weapon once
again be a big weapon preferably a big
two-handed axe with either one blade or
two blades one on each side it doesn't
really matter to me either way I feel
like a big weapon would really help this
character for the starting armor it
would definitely be a bit of standard
leather with similar pieces that kind of
like Rader does and the high level gear
should be armor with first surrounding
it so that we can keep that Viking feel
to it
for the move set the Barbarian should
definitely have a charged heavy that
swings him around and will hit all the
opponents in a single radius with
regardless of they're in front or behind
him the Barbarian is also used to using
his hand so possibly similar to
Centurion he could punch the opponent or
mate or maybe after a guard break or
during one of his combos that would
cause a stun effect since he would punch
them very hard I also have one idea for
the specific feed for him that would be
to cause a mini earthquake nothing huge
but within the area he would stomp on
the floor causing the ground to shake a
bit causing all opponents in that area
to stagger back a bit preventing them
from attacking during the shockwave it
wouldn't last very long its main uses
when in a teamfight to get the upper
hand on the opponents and stop their
attack from doing just about one attack
so for example if an opponent is on the
floor and it Bob ringer is about to
deliver that killing unblockable blow
you shattered the ground a bit and it
prevents him from doing that move and
thus saving your teammate the cooldown
would be have to be a little bit long
since a video if it wasn't it would be a
little bit of a spam fest and that's
probably not what the devs want if this
was the case if they were to add this
character lastly for the barbarian is
the executions and the one idea for the
barbarian I have is to punch the
opponent and stun them and then come in
with a swift deadly accident which would
decapitate the head or a very brutal
body shot the other execution would be
to kick would be a kick that would knock
the opponent on his side to where they
are facing the barbarian as they watch
as the barbarian decapitates them over
all the Barbarian is going to be another
slow bow hard-hitting character as well
but with a different few different moves
and for a final character we have the
monk he would be a samurai character and
he would either fall into the hybrid or
vanguard-class
for the monk I would want him to have no
weapons in strictly use his hands but
wear gloves kind of like brass knuckles
or if we have to have a weapon I'd
prefer
that the monks outfit at the start would
be regular cloth outfit similar to a
stereotypical monk you would see in
China or in Japan
to then become a war complex outfit with
more layers and possibly more armor on
the hands and legs there could also be
some variation and looks like a
different beard or head tattoo as well
his moveset would consist of fast lights
and some average heavies but the heavies
wouldn't do much damage since he is
using a staff or his fists
I want the motion of these moves to be
very fluent since he is a monk and he
masters the way of his weaponry he
should also have some soft faints and
his moveset as well considering he would
be using his hands or staff as opposed
to the previous characters I mentioned
which are wielding incredibly large
heavy weapons for an actual move he
should have an infinite combo of light
attacks that that is similar to how
conker does to give him that Fist of
Fury feel as well as calm calm blowing
some kicks and punches and moves
together we don't have a lot of
characters in the game that have a lot
of kick moves
I believe shinobi and maybe Highlander
and a couple other characters have a few
kick moves but they don't do all any
damage I feel like the monk should be
able to do damage with this kicks and
his punches and some I'll have to combo
into both of them maybe the light
attacks could be the punches and the
heavy attacks could be the kicks and you
can combo into those so maybe like
one-two punch to it like a little
roundhouse kick something like that to
give him that extra feel another move
that would work really well is a
sweeping light attack that knocks the
opponent on the floor if they are hit by
it for the feats I only really have one
idea and that's the ability to heal his
teammates by like a banner or some
spiritual essence seeing as he is a monk
and you might know a thing or two about
that and then lastly for the monk are
the executions and if the monk is using
only his hands I feel like he could
pinpoint the pressure points in the
opponent which could lock up their body
and then stop them from moving and
basically kill them right there or if
he's using his staff he could sweep
their opponents legs and smash the staff
on top of their head and that's about it
those are gonna be my ideas for the
creations of the three characters in for
honor that I personally like to see in
year two once again shout out to Tony
and Raven for the inspiration of this
video this is a lot of fun to make but
it was really difficult to make because
I'm really not a creative person but it
was a lot of fun trying to make your own
character because then possibly the devs
could see these videos that me Tony and
Raven made and then we can even get our
own character into the game which is
always nice to see if you like the video
please sure to give it a like if you
have a character you want to see in for
leave it in the comments below it the
same way that I did showing off or
talking about the outfits the move sets
in the
cocoons defeats all that good stuff I'd
love to hear your opinion on it
subscribe if you're new to foreigner I
covered the news the leaks and the
information about foreigner hit the bell
next to it to stay notified of all my
uploads community posts and future
streams my recent video should be on
screen now as well with that have a
great day guys and peace out